faster harder louder the 27th edition of
Bakken takes its motto as seriously as
its lineup among this year's headliners
British metal legends iron may they're
joined by their compatriots Saxon
we played it first in 92 got a thousand
people in here so it's grown over there
and it's grown from word of mouth so
it's great festival because it's one of
big success stories of German music
many of the big stars at Falcon are
regular guests including German singer
Jennifer Hoffman and her band beyond the
black it's like coming back home really
what I really love here is that people
the fans are so friendly so peaceful so
respectful 5,000 personnel are on hand
to make sure everything goes smoothly
after several terrorism related attacks
in Germany recently security is tight
this year bags are not allowed but the
crowd won't let that dampen their
spirits
Buchan is mud rain and beer
never ever not once a year the global
metal community descends on sleepy
little Vulcan the festival means a big
boost for locals in terms of both
business and free entry the people are
just so adorable and everyone sticks
together and helps each other out
there's never any trouble either it's
just wonderful
here someone asks where you're from and
you say [ __ ] no further questions
beside the local church in Bakken is
turned into a distinctly unholy venue
during the festival later on here
Finland's Tarija turnin will be
performing her trademark mash-up of
classical music and metal for me metal
is representing really beauty is
representing something really beautiful
of course I can be hard and heavy and
rock hard and loud and but it's not only
that it's filled with beautiful with
melodies and beautiful harmonies and
what better example of the festival's
diversity of styles than the opening act
the local fire department banned pumps
up the volume as the action gets going
offstage as well